erst am abend haben sie sich also mal
wieder getroffen die koalitionsspitzen
zu einer krisensitzung die energie und
spritpreise das kriegen sie mit jeder
der tanken geht oder gas bestellen muss
die explodieren in die bundeswehr soll
plötzlich unglaublich viel geld fließen
und das am besten bei einem und da fragt
man sich schon wie das gehen soll
soliden haushalt ja und nicht zu
vergessen es liegen zwei jahre pandemie
hinter uns mehr dazu jetzt von dirk
jacobs
etwas geringere ausgaben als in den
letzten beiden coroner jahren aber immer
noch sehr hohe plant der bund für dieses
jahr aufgrund des regierungswechsels
steht ja haushalt etwas später als
üblich zur debatte der entwurf von
finanzminister lindner sieht 400 57,6
milliarden euro vor bei einer
neuverschuldung von knapp unter 100
milliarden hinzu kommen aber noch die
jüngst beschlossenen 100 milliarden euro
für die bundeswehr über einen mit
zusätzlichen krediten finanzierte
sondervermögen abseits der
schuldenbremse schulden sind es trotzdem
und das sind nicht die einzigen ausgaben
die in folge des ukraine krieges noch
zusätzlich entstehen die aufnahme der
flüchtlinge und die steigenden
energiekosten machen bereits jetzt einen
noch zu ermittelnden ergänzungs haushalt
unausweichlich höhe bisher unklar der
finanzminister unterstrich dabei dass
man finanzielle schocks für die bürger
abfedern und menschen vor dem verlust
ihrer existenz schützen werde schränkte
aber ein
langfristig ist realistischerweise klar
dass der staat einen allgemeinen verlust
an wohlstand der sich aus steigenden
weltmarktpreisen für energieimporte gibt
ebenso wenig ausgleichen kann wie das
individuelle unternehmerische risiko
die großen finanziellen anstrengungen
für die energiewende aus
klimaschutzgründen kommen auch noch
hinzu und so ändert sich an der enormen
neuverschuldung des staates vorerst
nichts lag die früher noch deutlich
unter 50 milliarden euro und dann sogar
sechs jahre lang bei der berühmten
schwarzen null so ist es nun das dritte
jahr nacheinander mit kürzlich noch
nicht für denkbar gehalten dreistelligen
milliardensummen große lasten auch für
die zukunft
und jetzt begrüße ich christian doerr
den fdp fraktionsvorsitzenden im
bundestag guten morgen guten morgen ich
grüße sie was ist denn gestern beim
treffen der koalitionsspitzen
herausgekommen ihr finanz minister
christian lindner der hatte ja im
vorfeld schon vor zu hohen erwartungen
an staatshilfen gewarnt es geht darum
die menschen jetzt in deutschland zu
entlasten insbesondere angesichts der
gestiegenen benzinpreise an den
tankstellen und da sind wir uns einig
sehen sie es mir nach dass ich jetzt
nicht im detail aus verhandlungen
berichtet aber die ampel koalitionäre
verhandeln vertrauensvoll hinter
verschlossenen türen aber dass
gemeinsames ziel ist jetzt die menschen
zu entlasten
das haben wir vor ein paar wochen ja
schon bewiesen in einem ersten schritt
haben wir ein entlastungspaket in höhe
von knapp 16 milliarden euro beschlossen
das wird jetzt im bundestag auf den weg
gebracht und alle sind sich einig dass
es auch weitere entlastung braucht und
aus unserer sicht insbesondere für
diejenigen die in deutschland auf das
auto angewiesen sind ich muss dann
natürlich trotzdem noch mal nachfragen
weil das unsere zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer ja brennend interessiert die
frage wie die bundesregierung die
steigenden sprit und energiepreise
abfedern will abfedern kann worüber sie
also da gesprochen haben denn die frage
ist ja gibt es den tank rabatt wie vom
finanzminister gewünscht oder das
mobilitäts geld wie zb von der spd
vorgeschlagen also sie erwähnen ist es
liegen verschiedene modelle auf dem
tisch darüber reden wir jetzt derzeit in
der ampelkoalition ich habe gestern
abend zur kenntnis genommen dass auch
der bundesvorsitzende der grünen
beispielsweise sagen dass bei den
benzinpreisen was passieren und wir
sehen das ja bei unseren europäischen
nachbarn in frankreich beispielsweise in
italien polen oder auch schweden die
alle machen was an der tankstelle ich
denke da braucht es entlastung aber wir
reden darüber was der einfachste und vor
allerdings schnellste weg ist ein modell
was jetzt monate oder ein halbes jahr
braucht das hilft uns natürlich nicht
weiter die menschen brauchen jetzt
entlastung insbesondere die vielen
menschen die zur arbeit pendeln und
gerade im ländlichen raum eben auf das
auto angewiesen sind insgesamt sind das
natürlich wirklich große große summen an
geld über die wir hier reden 100
milliarden für die bundeswehr 200
milliarden für den klimaschutz das sind
schon mal allein drei milliarden euro
und dann kommt noch der rest dazu also
da muss man doch ganz ehrlich sagen
solide rechnen und wirtschaften das geht
in dieser lage einfach nicht ganz so ist
es nicht wenn man sich den
bundeshaushalt im kern an schaut also da
wo wir zukunftsinvestitionen
beispielsweise in bildung sicherstellen
da reduzieren wir ja die schulden
deutlich mehr machen war halb so viele
schulden wie es die große koalition noch
getan hat aber nichtsdestotrotz ist
neuverschuldung ein grund warum wir ja
sagen wir wollen im kommenden jahr zur
schuldenbremse zurückkehren das ist ein
ganz wichtiger punkt wir sichern aber
auch dinge ab die jetzt notwendig
geworden sind weil sie in der
vergangenheit von der groko nicht
finanziert worden sind selbst einen
beitrag erwähnt die bundeswehr die
braucht jetzt unterstützung wir müssen
wieder wehrhaft werden die
verteidigungsfähigkeit deutschlands muss
gewährleistet sein das machen wir mit
einem sondervermögen speziell für die
bundeswehr aber im kernhaushalt des
bundes sichern wir die
zukunftsinvestitionen ab und das bei
deutlich weniger schulden indem wir uns
auf den kern konzentrieren das was der
staat machen muss damit es in
deutschland weiter voran geht und wir
übrigens auch wirtschaftlich stark
bleiben das ist ja in so einer krise
besonders wichtig denn unsere
geopolitische stärke auch gegenüber
russland ist unsere wirtschaftliche
stärke und darauf setzt die jetzt müssen
wir nur schauen wie man das müssen sie
nur schauen wie sie das ganze auch
umsetzen denn für den geplanten
ergänzungs haushalt daher die folgen des
krieges auch abfedern soll braucht die
regierung wegen der nötigen
grundgesetzänderung eine
zweidrittelmehrheit deswegen also auch
angewiesen auf zustimmung der union die
in teilen doch skeptisch ist was bieten
sie der union also was sie ansprechen
ist dass sogar diese sondervermögen was
wir im grundgesetz absichern wollen für
die bundeswehr und da sind wir in
gesprächen mit der union die sagt das
soll vor allen dingen für die bundeswehr
zur verfügung stehen und ich glaube da
sind wir uns im grundsatz einig ist doch
klar dass wir jetzt nicht einfach geld
aufnehmen was dann irgendwo hin fließt
sondern die bundeswehr braucht jetzt
unterstützung und ich bin dankbar dass
auch die bundesverteidigungsministerium
gesagt hat das geld fließt jetzt nicht
einfach so sondern auch die bundeswehr
bekommt strukturreformen in der
vergangenheit gab es ja sehr teure
rüstungsprojekte die nicht funktioniert
haben das werden wir ändern also gehen
auch da gut mit dem geld der
steuerzahler oben und ich glaube da sind
wir uns mit der größten
oppositionspartei der cdu und csu auch
einig da kommt man sicherlich zusammen
ich bin da sehr zuversichtlich die
grundgesetzliche absicherung also zwei
drittel mehrheit im bundestag führt auch
dazu dass das geld wirklich dahin fließt
wo es ankommen soll und insofern bin ich
davon gut ist dass das auch klappt
morgen wird der haushaltsentwurf im
bundestag dann erstmals beraten
christian dürner dass der
fdp-fraktionsvorsitzende vielen dank für
das gespräch ich danke ihnen